there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey it's us again yeah we're
back in its episode 135 yeah we got
Rasputin on this one Rasputin and the
Romanovs yeah I actually was going to do
just the Romanovs but then I was kind of
like well I'm not sure if that would
like extend a whole show and Rasputin is
related because he was you know at their
port and like had a lot of influence on
them and might have had something to do
with what ultimately ended up happening
to them so I figured it would just be
kind of a cool narrative ginnis gonna be
on point and I'm gonna be banging on all
cylinders cuz this topic here is a
[ __ ] wild topic some [ __ ] to say
about this you know there is so much
crazy [ __ ] about this and even to this
day again no one is quite sure how much
of it is true and how much of it is
exaggerated we went into this a little
bit like on our countess Bathory show
and our flat the Impaler show cuz I feel
like a lot of the really outlandish
stuff particularly about Rasputin may
have been exaggerated because there was
like a lot of reason there was a lot of
people that hated him and so you know
there was a lot of reason to like
fabricate [ __ ] about him like even one
he was alive and even after he was dead
there was a lot of bizarre [ __ ] it was
thought there was like a lot of true
[ __ ] that was crazy about him yeah
situation you know
Nix yeah what the hell the Romanovs were
up to you know to it to allow a lot of
stuff that he had done yeah it is ours
family to this arena and all those yeah
as weird I mean yeah it is kind of a
strange story and I feel like I mean I
didn't know them and it's like you know
whatever side of it you're on like it
there are really no heroes in this story
it's like everyone's kind of terrible
but I mean other than the little kids
because they do but you know regardless
of how you feel about it it was just
it's a very bizarre situation and I
it would make a really good story now I
should say that the reason I've been
wanting to do a show about the Romanovs
was because of this book and I have
shown this on the show many many times
because I had this book growing up and I
loved this book this is strange stories
amazing facts now this was put out by
Reader's Digest and this came out in the
1970s
now before 1991 there abouts nobody
actually knew where the Romanovs were
very least known in the West so there
were many many rumors that you know some
or all of the Romanovs other than Czar
Nicholas had escaped there were a lot of
stories like particularly the 30s and
40s Asya stories yeah about like people
claiming to be a Nastasia people
claiming to be Alexei because those were
usually the two because even in the 90s
when they did find a grave - two of the
skeletons were missing so that kind of
played into all these conspiracy
theories about you know they lived and
like maybe this woman was a Nastasia and
maybe this was Alexei and all these
stories but spoiler alert as of 2007 or
2008 all of the bodies have been found
yeah they were all killed in the cellar
yeah both at the same time Bolsheviks
got them all on the same day yeah so
there was never so anybody you know
anybody that was you know later on came
along and said that they were one of the
Romanovs was either mistaken or trying
to pull one over on somebody yeah so
we'll get into that a little bit too and
like I said that was one of the most
fascinating things because I think even
as a kid I was like super morbid as you
can see and it was something I never
really grew out of why she she do what
she does well I don't know it's just I
was always a very morbid person and it's
like I just always was fascinated by
morbid things so when I had that book
the whole story about the Romanov family
being gunned down in the cellar like
even the little kids that freaked me the
[ __ ] out and so it really stuck with me
and then I kind of like kept following
it over the years and like I said it was
only the like probably 10
years ago that they actually finally
found out what happened because there
was a whole big article in there about
this girl that claims she was Anasazi
and all these people who came and said
yeah it's totally her and it does kind
of look like her but yeah she has a hike
yeah I'm not really like that I'm I
consider myself more of a man of action
you know with military background I got
no problem with running around and you
know shooting people you know that
doesn't bother me
it's just weird necrophilia she'd be
looking into necrophilia cases and stuff
you can go back on somebody's old there
was one show I had to walk out of about
well yeah house couldn't take that's
that still makes me laugh when I think I
don't like that man that took me over to
over the edge on that one that [ __ ] just
got too damn nasty did get too gross
well like I said it's like I can't
really explain it and I guess if you
don't I think I was kind of born that
way I have some chicken kind of genetic
predisposition toward creepy [ __ ] I
can't explain it any other way because I
remember being a really little kid and
being like go so which is the murderous
yeah and that was like all I ever wanted
to like read about and it's hard to
explain to somebody that doesn't get
it's not like I enjoy it necessarily
it's not like I'm like just little Bob
you see it doesn't really bother me much
you guys but I think I'm within like the
realm of the more like the normal
spectrum I mean I could yeah you
probably got no problem with violence as
long as it's like a goal-directed
violent spray or it's two guys or two
parties that are willingly you know I
mean shooting it out with each other
to achieve something I understand that
yeah I mean I could even understand
somebody coming back [ __ ] over
somebody else in retribution I get my
bench I can I just can't stand any that
weird senseless [ __ ] you know I made
like hanging those little girls and like
oh BTK did or just you know I just I
don't understand that [ __ ] that makes
you mad man it makes me mad too makes me
want to kill those dudes when they do
that well I feel like that too but for
some reason it's like because
maybe it's just because I'm just like
why what's going on in there what's
going on is it I just it just fascinates
me like what can go so wrong in
someone's brain I can't fathom senseless
homicide yeah yeah I mean most people
can yeah I can't you know but like I can
take I can go back into the ancient
Greece mentally ancient Rome and the
Roman period you know it was a virtue it
was a Roman virtue deduced to be
ruthless to your enemies as long as you
were good to your friends
yeah that's pretty human that that thing
you know I could understand that I just
can't understand being ruthless to a
person has done nothing hard nothing
like a random person there's some kind
of weird sex I'm gonna chop up that
person yeah which I keep reminding
people and you know I hear some feedback
from the crowd you know that they kind
of responded the same way like it makes
you furious you want to kill them yeah
you know understand that yeah I get
furious - yeah but then in another way -
I find it fascinating because like I
said I want to understand what could go
so drastically awry in the human
experience that would cause someone to
do something like that yeah that's so
outside of our 10 human experience and
then we got on that subject of those old
creepazoid necrophiliacs digging up
people you know to take them home just
like what they even occur to you I don't
know man that's what fascinates me why
would that even occur to you luckily
today's topic really won't be going down
there there is some combat in this one
you know well Rasputin got involved in
some calm baby shots danced and poisoned
and you know and then a freezing River
the Russian aristocracy they were not a
non-violent people yeah I mean they were
an honor based society if somebody had
to be taken out they did it
you know somebody disgraced somebody
else they did it no but you know that
era was like that um I don't know yeah
but like I said you know just saying you
know the thing with you know the thing
about the thing about Rasputin that has
fascinating me I mean other than all the
legends about like the man that couldn't
die and I mean he did but it took a lot
to kill him
and all this creepy [ __ ] about maybe he
was in this sex cult and all this other
stuff which they don't know if it's true
but I was like rumors about it but I
mean if you see pictures of the dude
that dude looks like a straight-up
psycho everything I've been jealous from
his [ __ ] eyes yeah everything I read
about the guy and all the evidence that
survives he shows the he exhibits the
behavior and the traits of a cult leader
yeah very much like a cult leader now a
cult leader usually had usually there's
sexual domination and weird physical
abuse involved in mind games yeah so I'm
just gonna say that those rumors were
probably true that's kind of once that's
just the way that that's the way that
psychological profile is yeah because
once they capture somebody's mind and
heart then they start abusing their
bodies sexuality you know start taking
advantage of the [ __ ] yeah and you know
he knew the Bible pretty well enough to
at least twist things and justify what
he was doing
even though by all accounts he was
probably illiterate doesn't matter as
long as you know the means if you know
the Christian means do you know what to
likes be about yeah you can so it sounds
like you because I guess most other
people were illiterate matter really
when you analyze Christianity archaic
Christianity you go into a church and
you see scenes on stained glass windows
of certain scenes from the New Testament
it's mostly what you're saying really
you can boil Christianity down to those
memes that's all it is
yeah you know I mean there's not really
anything deeper to it than that we've
done other shows on the subject you know
you know if you you know to understand
what what I'm talking about go back and
look at our Robert dr. Robert and price
show where dr. price was on as our guest
and we talk about it you know their
Christianity is not complicated it's
very simple really when you break it
down yeah yeah it's it's a resurrection
call yeah and the thing that they had I
mean if he was indeed involved in this
cult that he is often accused of it was
just an offshoot of the Russian Orthodox
Church where they took things like
flagellation and
you know kind of sexual stuff to purify
right you like her xox pH or cigarettes
or whatever so that you look at the
right from the Russian Orthodox when you
look at it from the Russian Orthodox
angle it makes a lot of sense that he
was telling these girls to do this yeah
yeah I mean that would that fits right
in yeah yeah you could you could stretch
the Russian Orthodox Gestalt into that
and I mean the Romanov family to one
they were very into they were very
religious and they were very open to
mysticism and other mystics and prophets
and things like that it was and also
they were very uh closer didn't really
get out there weren't worldly right yeah
they didn't really get out into the real
world much and they had like a lot of
tragedies you know or a lot of things
that could be exploited yeah and I think
that they probably knew how to exploit
those weaknesses tubes yeah because I
mean this guy you know
grigory rasputin born in 1869 out in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere in Siberia
yeah um
peasant family pretty much you know who
ran a farm or some [ __ ] like that
um they I it's funny because they don't
actually know much about him like his
childhood there's like a lot of legends
about his child like he was this Hellion
and he was like a horse thief and you
know he he did like very like petty
crimes and [ __ ] like that but no one's
entirely sure if that's true or not is
that bringing was probably really
typical for the time and it probably was
yeah um again they're speculating that
he was probably illiterate just because
most people of his time and station
would have been you would have checked
out that he was but yeah it's it that
doesn't that's not to say that he didn't
learn to read later on but they say he
was probably like illiterate when he
grew up yeah which illiteracy really
isn't isn't really especially back in
those days that doesn't mean anything
about somebody's intelligence no of
course on earlier show it I would talked
about a guy that I knew in Mississippi
is one of my dad's friends who's my
dad's
generation he was illiterate but ran a
successful business and had secretaries
doing most of the work
yeah never would have known that that
did couldn't really well yeah by the
time his forties came around he did
learn how to read and write yeah but he
never really used it much interest
because of his early childhood
upbringing where he came from you know
he never made it to school yeah but that
dude could make a lot of money no the
thing about it is that when you grow up
illiterate you find ways of getting what
you got around it right I mean you know
people are adaptable yeah he was super
intelligent real you know and he did it
through charisma yeah basically he
succeeded to charisma and you know he
was what's the word I'm looking for he
was not not conniving but he was what's
a good why he was never mind so story
goes that he was leading this life he
may or may not have been a thief he may
or may not have been violent and getting
a true he was running whatnot cunning
that was the word I was like yeah he was
a very cunning man well like I said as
long as you know how to work around
stuff and you know how to delegate then
you can get by yep and like I said
particularly back in these days that
we're talking about you know yeah
there's no technology when a lot of
people were illiterate so it wasn't
unusual
you're right um you know so you didn't
have to surf the web back then that's
what I mean so in a way the society was
more accommodating toward you just
becoming in Russia during that time
especially as a peasant you probably
would very rarely ever even see paper so
what would you need well I don't need to
I mean your whole life we she probably
just lived on a farm and the only book
you'd run across would be the Bible and
all having a priest had it yeah yeah
that's probably exactly right so
evidently like I said he's doing this
[ __ ] or whatever now he does actually
marry at one point he met a girl that
lived in the like the next village over
and married her now they had a bunch of
kids but I think only three or four of
them lived into adulthood which again
very common back then particularly in
that time and situation however when he
was 28 years old
he had some sort of religious awakening
or
he said um sources vary some of them
said oh we saw you know the vision of
the Virgin Mary Burge and Mary or he
just had some kind of religious
awakening where he said I'm gonna go be
a traveling you know holy man and like
go tell people about blah blah blah so
in 28 years old he leaves his wife and
kids and goes wandering around like like
a not a cop not a wandering mystic you
might want to call that a bomb and like
I said you know if you see him pictures
of him cuz there are a lot of pictures
of him dude looks like a crazy-ass
[ __ ] so it's like I I almost
feel like if he walked into your town
and was like wanted to preach to you
some [ __ ] you would like to sit there
and listen because you'd be scared to
say no cuz you'd be afraid you'd be like
[ __ ] go and psycho on yours and [ __ ]
I have never seen such crazy eyes on a
person I must admit if you look at when
I look at old photos of Rasputin he's
working an angle he's really trying to
look as free plus might have been the
drugs there and it's kind of like he's a
prototype of Marilyn Manson I mean he
has a rock star thing going yeah trying
to to me what I sensed by looking at the
photographs he's actually making a
conscious effort to project an image
across into the film and very similar to
the weirdness that you would find frog
in the goth scene and I think the people
of the day saw him is kind of like well
we kind of like Marilyn Manson for our
generation yeah you look at the oh look
what the Phelps that and he was a priest
that looked like that
yeah which back in those days that
probably would have given you a little
bit more of a you know I mean it would
have more it would have been a little
more mysterious well he definitely was
that and I think that that was a lot of
his appeal I mean not saying that he
wasn't a controversial figure even
before he got mixed up
with the Romanovs you know even back
then now people call him the mad monk
and things he technically was not a
monkey technically was not a priest he
wasn't anything he's just like you
didn't get any kind of title or any kind
of diploma no I remember most people
considered him to be priests like figure
but it was yeah it was almost kind of
like a dark version of it yeah like a
rock star version being a priest like I
said he still was a controversial figure
like there were some religious figures
that thought that that he was demonic or
had demonic powers because one of the
things he built himself as a healer a
mystic and he could like had prophecies
about the future like Nostradamus say if
you had priests saying that he had
demonic powers that may have added to
his mystique yeah people believed in
that [ __ ] must have I mean he had to
have something to just come out of this
like nowhere peasant village and get
into the highest echelons of Russian
aristocracy well it could have only like
in only a few years it could have only
been one thing that did it that was just
charisma yeah he could pull me in he
knew people yeah because that was how he
got like an introduction to the family
and all that other kind of stuff like it
was through people that he knew at
various places through his travels he
had to have known how to look how to
behave and what to say at the right time
to the right person and he was probably
had a very accurate very good way of
sizing someone up we have that checks
that that checks out with the kind of
like the cult leader yeah I mean the
mentality of a cult leader you know
that's one of things that they can do is
size somebody up to seek out a weakness
same of the comment yeah and it
definitely does seem like he was very
adept at doing them right just lookin at
lookin at somebody and figure out what
it is that you know what is there ruined
us as if that's what Scientology would
say you know I mean what is it that's
bothering this person and I'll approach
him from that you know from that angle
ya know that's all he was doing very
observant probably yeah
putting his crazy eyes on yeah yeah he
would have been a really perceptive and
observant guy somebody who was paying
attention to details and could read body
language you know yeah and understand
things like voice stress inflection to
be able to read somebody yeah nowadays
you'd call that you'd call that it's go
something that a Mentalist would do yeah
like a cold reading yeah like a cold
reading that's what your best Mentalist
magicians are really really good at that
so he's probably doing that yeah maybe
he learned that learned how to do that
through kind of like a life of crime in
his earlier years yeah maybe like
pickpocket something real petty like I
said he's been accused of like horse
thievery yeah you know things of that
nature getting in fights that kind of
[ __ ] yeah so it wasn't a [ __ ] of
respite was a badass and he could
intimidate the [ __ ] out of you
well like I said look how long it took
to kill him I mean even even the [ __ ]
that's not exaggerated it's still pretty
hardcore yeah you know oh by the way by
the time you hear in this dis recording
unseen hands should be in its second
audio edition so all her I mean I
finished editing it and I uploaded it
you know we're recording this probably
like a week before it goes up so it
might be a little longer than that but
if but it should be a few days after
this Corral because I just uploaded the
new files today so improved audio on the
unseen hands if you go on if you go on
Amazon
what problem Amazon will probably tell
you somewhere that it's a second edition
yeah because you they they've done that
right well it's they put it in the
description in description that like you
know as of you know March 2019
you know audio quality improved audio
quality whatever blows that's great so
now that that's done and bliss well that
was that was a smooth transition from
the show into a damn plug wasn't it cuz
I know just who you just blindsided me
with that [ __ ] cuz I've been drinking
but you haven't you [ __ ] is that such
personal and is this [ __ ] here is like
a double compared to what my normally
would drink though okay yes that's
strong um I ran an orange juice so I get
cranberry right cool cool con and have a
lot of people on my Facebook group
called shitty movies with Shi ddy duties
yeah you can you can find me there on
Facebook yeah where I talk about the
shitty movies which are good movies but
they're bad movies anyway a lot of a lot
of people from England and all around
the world or asked me what the recipe to
this is equal parts silver tequila guava
nectar and pineapple yes that's that's
Lord Kukulcan I thirst that I've heard
that people in the UK were having a hard
time getting guava nectar though I'm
having a hard time getting guava nectar
since it was always gone yeah you guys
are buying it up will you [ __ ] like
who live in Sanford that are like better
by another guava okay we'd like all the
other juices were there in the guava
nectar was like empty Oh hardcore
Central American tropic that's ramp got
all these local Mexicans buying a la but
still had mango oh yeah just agava and
they didn't have the Goya I don't know
why see we have where we live it's if
you don't live in the south we have
Publix which is like the best grocery
store I mean unless the high-class
that's the nice grocery store if you
well it's nice if you can't afford like
Whole Foods
although when Dix he's trying to compete
with it they're renovating all they have
to yeah they're renovating everything
when I was growing up when Dixie was
like the white trash well no maybe that
might have been Goodings but maybe that
was just where I live because I lived
locally Wiggly why did [ __ ] white
dress I didn't I didn't like grow up in
the hood I grew up like at the edge of
the hood
but yeah so Publix is kind of the nicer
story we have winn-dixie shed the
Challenger they got it they got it good
deli they do damn good meat actually but
Publix we have like one on one side of
us and one like on the other side like
you go out like the street that we live
on and then you go left and we have a
Publix and we go right
so it's like sometimes we try to go back
and forth and sometimes they don't have
the same [ __ ] even though the public's
are only like two miles apart maybe more
than two miles maybe it's like three or
four my best sub sandwiches the best
sandwiches you can get it for real their
deli is like that they're like five
sandwiches
man [ __ ] subway yeah yeah if you live
yes in the South you know public subs
are the best and the fried chicken
that's it yeah the fried chicken yeah
public subs better than Subway obviously
better better than Jimmy John's better
than better than all that [ __ ] yeah yeah
that sounds all right so where was I was
talking about Rasputin we'd give it a
plug to a damn grocery story that's not
this [ __ ] fight this is that this is
the [ __ ] show I tell you that's where
it won't
we just we plugged what we want to plug
in even past well like I said it's not
even a plug cuz we're just talking about
[ __ ] we like yeah like you know what I
mean they want a baby they can but they
don't have to I'm charging these [ __ ]
you start charging show that's how you
know that our opinions are that are
legit because we don't get any money
from you don't get any money money we
all make money off patreon they don't
have to pay shedder doesn't have to pay
us I just really like shudder I'm just
like what five dollars a month and I can
see all the horror movies I want yes
please yeah and they have such a good
[ __ ] I would rather have shudder than
Netflix but Netflix has a couple series
that we have to keep so good to keep
Netflix because of a couple series yeah
MST 3000 and honestly like I said on the
last show Netflix has actually been
trying to up their game they added some
older [ __ ] yeah in fact last night we
just watched demon Sweeney Todd Demon
Barber of Fleet Street the one with
Johnny Depp in it yeah and I had
forgotten I saw that in the theater back
in 2007 and I was like I'd forgotten how
good entertaining that was yeah yeah I'd
forgotten how gory it was too and I was
like yay so anyway all right so along
comes the year 1904 now Rasputin has
made his way to st. Petersburg the seat
of the
Romanov family now the Romanovs have
ruled Russia for over 300 years
damn yeah this is my imperial family not
kings or anything like that eg emperors
and whatnot so yeah they've ruled for a
very long time however they are although
they didn't know it at the time they
were the last of the room and I was the
last of the Imperial families to rule
Russia because this was the end of
everything although like I said they
didn't know it at the time yeah well
yeah that the modern era started to come
yeah um so by the time Rasputin got
there in 1904 things weren't great in
Russia at the time and Tsar Nicholas
let's talk a little bit about Tsar
Nicholas and this arena Alexandra um the
thing about Tsar Nicholas as I said his
family had ruled Russia for you know
many generations but Nicholas even as a
child was not super jazzed about wanting
to be Tsar he evidently saw his
grandfather assassinated by a bomb he
was like blown to pieces when he was a
little kid um and he's just like yeah
that's just not something I want to do
so he was kind of like a reluctant czar
and by all accounts he was very weak
willed very indecisive um it was like I
said it was just not a job he wanted and
he was clearly not very you know
interested in doing it so I think
Society suffered because of it I mean he
would reportedly he would like leave his
big decisions like till the last minute
and then he would just kind of go along
with whatever the last person that
advised him and said hey you should do
this he's like yeah good idea let's just
do that for a while it is said that the
joke in Russia was that the two most
powerful people in Russia where's our
Nicholas and the last person that talked
to him the Romanoff the imperial family
in their history I mean for the past
like
100 years before this was pretty bad
even you could probably go back to about
150 years before this there's a lot of
mental problems lots of hemophilia well
yeah that really it started to look like
what you saw in the equestrian families
of ancient Rome lots of madness well
inbreeding
yeah I was in bringing I think it was a
lot of it and just ruthlessness yeah
that too there's still a lot of
mysteries about you know you know from
that era I mean there was Ivan the
Terrible who was pretty terrible but he
wasn't dumb and we're still looking for
his damn library and then we got to do a
show on that one day oh yeah we meant to
do that actually yeah no Asiago Moscow
or either Moscow st. Petersburg no I
think it was Moscow's totally undermined
with tunnels stone tunnels we made
everything go here underground [ __ ] yeah
most of them are too dangerous to go
into but somewhere in those tunnels is
Ivan the terrible's lost library and in
it are a bunch of [ __ ] missing books
stuff that came you know stuff that was
stuff that the originals were destroyed
during the burning of the Library of
Alexandria like different versions of
was it Shakespeare no different versions
of the Bible were in there that had
different books that are gone there's
all contexts for that's several hundred
yeah I forgot what it was there was oh
no I read what it was there's an older
version of a Roman history book that
they want to find and evidently it was
on the list of one of the missing books
the entitlement and in that book it was
before the Christian Church the Catholic
Church had changed history so in there
may have been what real Roman history
was during the time of Jesus yeah they
want that one so I toniest
know yeah
Tacitus yeah my sweet oh no no the one
the one written by the Jewish author the
the antiquity of the Jews okay it was a
Roman writer and said you know Jewish
history book and in that that was
written during the time of the time in
which Jesus supposedly would have lived
and they want that Edition it's a first
edition you know before it had been
altered because it had been altered by
the Catholic Church and some stuff that
have been inserted in there you know to
Catholic Church they're kind of
responsible for a lot of the animation
being lost there was that book to land
historical credence to the existence of
a historical Jesus yeah uh you know
probably wasn't a historical Jesus as he
seems to be a mythical character yeah
I'm like I said we went into that would
Robert prices on the show yeah dr. price
will tell you all about that but yeah
sorry to break it to you people that guy
may have not existed yeah you know all
right so like I said now Czar Nicholas
as much as he did not like to be czar
now to his credit um he and his wife
unusually for this type of marriage you
know royal marriages were usually
undertaken for you know reasons of
political expediency but that does not
seem to be the case um they actually did
they met at a wedding when one of the I
remembered it Josephus oh that's what it
was the book one of those books but from
Josephus anyway I didn't mean it
this is thirteen o'clock this had
thirteen o'clock rolls all right so they
met at a wedding when they were both
were teenagers I believe Nicholas was
fifteen or sixteen and I think Alexandra
was 12 now then later much later on they
married and by all accounts they were
completely and totally in love with one
another so it wasn't like I said it
wasn't one of those marriages of
convenience or whatever
that they actually were you know from
examining their letters and stuff like
that they actually were like a unified
pair and all this other kind of stuff
now interestingly Alexandra who became
the czarina she was the granddaughter of
Queen Victoria she'd actually been born
in Germany the czarina not Queen
Victoria and as you mentioned before she
carried the gene for hemophilia yeah
sometimes called the Royal disease
because it goes in royal families
although interestingly on a personal
note my family also carries it hmm
most my grandfather had it several of my
aunt's and so my cousins are also have
it not that I know of
I've never been tested even though my
but you know yeah yeah it's like I don't
think I have it but some of my like
other aunts and cousins have it to
varying degrees and actually some of my
cousin has a son that had like that has
full-blown because usually it usually
women carry it and men get it not always
because I have a couple of aunts that
interestingly I'm not going to mention
their names or anything like that but I
have a couple of aunts they're twins and
they have it and they manifest it mmm
and that is so unusual that they were
like subject to study when they were big
problems with haemophilia is damn
internal bleeding it's okay you get a
cut on the outside you can find that up
if you ever have any internal bleeding
that's it you just that's what I mean
your [ __ ] so you really really really
have to wanna get hurt you have to watch
it yeah so the problem being okay so
Tsar Nicholas and Zarina Alexandra they
um started having children and of course
just like every other royal family
pretty much they needed a male heir
however the first four kids that they
had were all girls Tatyana Olga Maria
and later anastacio finally finally they
had a boy
Alexei however
he had hemophilia really really bad so
they tried to keep this a secret because
they were already on some pretty shaky
political ground you know there have
been like labor strikes there have been
all kind of like revolutionary rumblings
like in Russia at the time you know
people were like we don't need the
monarchy or whatever they called it the
imperial families and we're starting to
kind of push back against it conditions
were not very good and you know they
didn't like the room at our family that
we're in because they felt like they
just kept making poor decisions they
kept losing all these wars they had been
in a war with Japan that they lost and
all these other kind of things so they
were not super popular so they didn't
want anyone to know that Alexei had
hemophilia because they thought you know
if they thought that he was going to die
and the line wasn't going to continue
then that might like foment revolution
or MIT you know like push revolution
forward kind of thing because people
would be like oh well that's the end of
that line let's get rid of these people
so they tried to keep it a secret that
Alexei had hemophilia now while this
whole [ __ ] was going on Rasputin turns
up in the court and he is able to like I
said as far as I know he didn't just
like turn up one day and be like hey I'm
Rasputin I'm gonna solve all your
problems he did know like other
religious figures and other monks and
things like that that you know knew
other people in court so he like got an
introduction and all this other stuff so
he shows up in court he gives them a
gift and things like that now he was
able to ingratiate himself with the
royal family by by some accounts knowing
that Alexei had hemophilia and being
able to cure it yes so he's mystified
now this is kind o could he do that this
is interesting and they're still kind of
talking about maybe what like how this
could have happened
now some sources say maybe he just had
some kind of weird like hypnosis thing
like maybe he could hypnotize yeah the
kid and it was like a psychosomatic type
of whatever that's what I always thought
it was or another thing too that has
been
elated is that okay back in those days I
mean I was there still not really a cure
for haemophilia not that I know of cause
like I said it runs in my family life
came here a family members habit but
back then you know they were even more
clueless about it so the only cute care
for it was to keep people aspirin which
if you know anything about aspirin would
make it worse because aspirin is a blood
thinner yeah and it's also kind of an
anti-inflammatory which means that
things wouldn't swell up and close up
they would just not swell up exactly
that makes sense
so some sources have speculated that
maybe all recipe did was say to the
doctor hey why don't you quit giving
that kid aspirin and maybe that might be
better no but I don't know how he would
have known unknown but may well it might
not even have been that it might have
just been the case of him you know
getting the doctors like you know
getting the doctors away from him you
know what I mean he had found a way to
cause blood to clot you can take
powdered aluminum and it'll cause blood
to clot it's possible like I said I
didn't have aluminum back then
I don't like any maybe there was
something he knew of maybe some kind of
a russian folk cure yeah that if you rub
something on a wound or touch the wound
but some kind of a powder blood mixed
with it and cause it to coagulate yeah
or to you know what I mean to make some
kind of glue you know it's just a little
wound and that's not you know I don't
know if you guys have ever seen powdered
aluminum they used to give it out into
old tiny shaving kits give her Knick to
yourself you could touch a little bit of
luminol to the knick and it would just
vanish yeah maybe he found something
like that it's possible like I said
maybe he had some kind of folk remedy me
yeah or like I said maybe just his
influence you know maybe the family
thought his influence was more
beneficial so they told the doctors to
back off and the doctor stopped giving
him aspirin and then it by all accounts
by all accounts somehow Rasputin
couldn't stop a kid from bleeding yeah
no one knows how but like yeah and the
czarina believed it
today I believe believed it you know a
wholeheartedly they thought he was the
only one that could stop that kid from
bleeding yeah and I'm gonna go ahead and
say that he could somehow yeah baby he
got some way of doing that I don't think
it was magic or no some amount of either
hypnosis or some kind of Russian folk
remedy he found in his travels yeah some
kind of a coagulant maybe that you could
maybe like hide a little bit of it in a
jar you know why they weren't looking
you could put someone your fingertip
yeah and then say some prayers and then
touch your do you think it's over the
top of it you know but somehow caused
that wound to seal itself yeah then you
could say that it it was some kind of a
magical power that you had or mystical
power that's what I think it was
something like that
yeah something that acted very similar
to powdered aluminum yeah I mean it's
possible that it might have just been
coincidental as well that you know kind
maybe the disease what is it wasn't as
bad when Rasputin has been there maybe
Rasputin was just able to calm the kid
down because by all accounts like I said
he was a very charismatic person he was
able to kind of chill everyone out
[Music]
you know everyone felt relaxed and
comfortable around him well not everyone
but it you know the the immediate room
and all family did um so really knows by
all accounts that I found it was
believed by the Yale family they did
believe that if he showed up he could
stop taking it from bleeding yeah he
knew something yeah all right
it was either some kind of a hypnosis
which I'm kind of kind of leaning away
from that I think somehow he had
discovered in his travels an
anticoagulant yeah of some sort
something you could rob on a cut yeah
and get it to coagulate to blood to
quite heavy or something to seal it like
a glue sort that's what I think it was
no I got no proof it's just a theory
because of you
old-timey shaving kids yeah you know
that you could do that back in the 40s
50s you know with some aluminum well
nowadays you can put like roll-on
deodorant like a yeah he mustered up
myself Souter I think somehow he found a
wrote folk remedy that could stop
bleeding that's what I'm going to say
yeah that's certainly possible yeah
because there's all kind of stuff in
nature that it was something like again
it wasn't something that was widely
known yeah you learn on a farm dealing
with animals yeah no I mean I don't
think that there's anything particularly
mysterious about because like I said
they tried to keep the fact that Aleksei
had hemophilia they try to keep that on
the down-low but the thing about
Rasputin is that he knew a lot of other
like court adjacent people um that might
have told him that so it's not like some
big mystery like how he showed up to
court and said oh I know your kid has
hemophilia even though nobody's supposed
to know that because a lot of other
people in the court knew it and he knew
a lot of other people in the court like
before he even went there yeah so I
think he could have got that info from
like other sources crazy ass siberian
folk remedy that you'd learn on a damn
farm where you know if you grab the
little blue stuff out of a [ __ ]
chicken [ __ ] and rubbed it on a cut it
stops the bleeding he might might have
an you don't really do that because I
don't know but it might have been
something that obscure he would only
know if you came up in a Siberian farm
yeah in a certain County you know
there's some kind of folk remedy that
actually worked and it was something
some commonly found you know I mean yes
substance if you put that in a cut it
stops the bleeding immediate yeah do it
through a chemical process yeah yeah I
bet you it was something like that yeah
and then if you if I told you if I could
go back in time you know if I could go
back in time and find out what it was
and tell you what he was doing it
probably [ __ ] hilarious yeah uh-huh
with a pride and some hilarious
hilarious little thing that his grandma
showed him when he was a little kid yeah
no I mean yeah Mr Price something like
that
I know I'm kind of wondering if like he
knew that specifically when he went
there because he must have known
Aleksei was their only male heir so he
would have been the next Czar had you
know had he lived it had the whole
assassination and whatnot no it happened
but so he must have known that that was
a weakness yeah because that kid was so
sickly and no one no one in the public
knew what was the matter with him right
but he's heard that if the kid had
haemophilia and they wouldn't bleed he
was a lot how to fix that and I might
have had some sense that might have been
because that was definitely one of the
major things that ingratiate him and it
pride wasn't anything supernatural or
high-tech well I knew it was something
as stupid as well you take a little bit
of chicken egg yolk and put it on it
wound and the enzymes you know main
cause coagulation yeah just pry
something that looks like it I don't
know if that works I don't know that's
true and pull down my ass let's say it
would have been something that a farmer
would have discovered by a gamete back
up and up in Siberia that's probably
what it was but putting deodorant on
your on your that works that works
though well are there other waxy
substances that will do that well and
well because deodorant like most interns
have aluminum oh that's why they tell
you not to wear them because they'll
maybe years you know that case you can
find in nature or around a you know I
mean around a farm that is similar to an
aluminum yeah it was gonna be something
dumb like that yeah but he knew about it
and he used it to his advantage
like a cunning man would like a con man
would yeah this is what he was he was a
con man I do kind of feel like yeah so
like I said you know him being able to
or at least their belief that he could
stop Alexie's bleeding was a major
factor in him like pretty much uh you
know not I'm not gonna say he like took
over their life or nothing like that but
he became a very trusted adviser to the
whole family
now here's where it starts to get creepy
because I mean it wasn't before
um because evidently the family saw no
problem in allowing Rasputin to hang out
with the four daughters in their bedroom
when they were in their little
nightgowns yeah this part always
mystified me and whatnot I was like I
said sources differ on this now if
Rasputin was because he certainly was a
horndog I don't think he made any secret
of that this dude had a rock star level
he was always like trying to bang him
prostitutes talk his way up your skirt
and a heartbeat the [ __ ] was a
ladies man II didn't well a couple
didn't even touch waters guy was dirty
he was dirty by all accounts he was a
filthy filthy dirty King dinky bum
dividual yeah damn bum why I don't rock
his [ __ ] crust punky
well that's what they call that he's a
crisp own [ __ ] nasty yeah it's like he
never [ __ ] like he would go to the
bathhouse with the prostitutes but he
wouldn't take a bath there no he would
just go in the room and beat them with a
belt and then leave without taking a
book yeah I'm just saying by some
accounts like I said no one's sure how
much of this is true or not but like it
was kind of a fantasy figure kind of
yeah I always want to say like Marketo
saw yeah but yeah so he was like super
dirty super gross he had crude the crazy
eyes and yet they let this dude hang out
and buy some accounts to like they said
he had like no shame he would just sit
there like pick his nose and like eat it
in front of people and [ __ ] like that
it's like just I don't know if he
thought that [ __ ] was funny cuz he's
like how much can I get away with and
they won't even like kick me out of here
it was just because I'm a mystic you
know I'm gonna be with my mystical nose
and eat my mystical book yeah it was
punk rock before punk rock existed there
most of it
[ __ ] up I spent something about him
you know I mean for him to have got that
far he had some kind of sexual magnetism
to him and he had you know [ __ ] it was
just you know it looks like a [ __ ]
freak and like I said had a big old
[ __ ] beak of a nose yeah people say
you know like a goat there was just
something about him the way he carried
himself he had some charisma I guess
some sort it must have been I mean he
must have had this counterculture
charisma that was very the opposite of
what what the opposite of what you would
find in it from in the Victorian era
then really Russia was still kind of in
a Victorian Victorian era I think that's
kind of the appeal of a lot of these
types of characters were the opposite
there so transgresseth they were
transgressive and [ __ ] but like they
were doing all this they're they're just
like doing all this crazy [ __ ] yeah they
smell really bad didn't even care man no
they didn't necessarily mean that [ __ ]
was good it just meant that it was grand
yeah we just transgressive well I'm just
saying that's probably what the
fascinate we're thinking it was [ __ ]
awesome because it was a breath of fresh
air from their point of view yeah
because I mean growing up and I'm not
gonna say it sucked because compared to
like the peasants at the time I'm sure
it was probably a [ __ ] breeze but you
know you lived your life you know very
sequestered you had a very stringent
like series of rules you had to adhere
to so some dude comes blowing it was
beard and crazy eyes and smelling like
ah yeah and picking his nose and wiping
it on everybody like hey that dudes kind
of neat yeah but the military
aristocracy of Russia guys who knew both
sides of the fence they were from rich
families but it also had military
experience and live Dino in the trenches
with the troops they saw him for what it
was they're like this is just a dirty
[ __ ] peasant yeah yeah I mean but
we'll get into that later yeah I I think
this dude here man he's a piece [ __ ]
that's the way that's the way they
eventually tried to kill him they did
kill him I guess well the new bings yeah
that's not fire to kill him yeah I think
but the thing is the guy that actually
did these were military base
no they were you yeah there were
military aristocracy so here's the thing
like I said we're not sure many people
who were in the household at the time
said that Rasputin had pretty much full
access to the daughters you know nursery
what it would have been at the time
where all the kids slept that he went in
there when they were getting ready for
bed like in their night clothes and
stuff now the girls have never said that
he did anything unpleasant to them he
just said he he called they called him
their friend they said he would just
come in and he would like read us
bedtime stories and he was really nice
and he would hug us and stuff and some
people have said you know he had kids of
his own maybe it was just a fatherly
true project but which maybe it was but
that didn't mean your wife was safe
though I don't know won't know for sure
yeah because this [ __ ] would get
into your wife quicker than [ __ ] that
yeah I don't think he was a pedophile
but he was about women well yeah he was
knocking down all that you and and he
wasn't asking permission either because
one of the women that worked in the
household later came out and accused him
of rape and the czarina was so all about
him that she fired that chick yeah
defended her she didn't believe it she
said he would never do that he's a holy
man oh he's alright he's looking for
every holy goodbye I get yes exactly
exactly and that's oh I think he was
accused of rape two times I think was
like two like you know it was a made and
make like maybe a nanny or something
like that I knew safe he could just take
that yeah that's what I'm thinking he
was like taking advantage yeah and like
I said he it was well known that he
would like hire prostitutes like a lot
yeah and he was known to kind of like
beat them up and [ __ ] like that also or
so you know so so he's trying to get the
sin out of them that's what he would
that's what you would tell them I was
trying to like purify purify my devil
out of me he's like let me just beat you
up and then I'll have to
I'll just live here and not take a bath
oh yeah nowadays we know exactly what
that is yeah that's [ __ ] BDSM me to
the finish [ __ ] yeah this is
like I said he's like a marquise design
good type of individual now it should be
said that even though you know the
czarina was super into it the kids were
super they loved him I guess they never
said anything never say that he was do
with children he might have been in yeah
I mean they were fairly young at this
point because the dude takes advantage
and he doesn't it doesn't necessarily
mean he's not good with kids
I think he's yeah I mean just cuz he's a
man wanna say that and a rapist do you
know I'm yeah but the reason why he got
to the place he got to in life is
because of kids so he had to have that
power of being a protector of children
yeah because yeah I mean he can he can
keep a kid from bleeding he can keep all
the kids happy and the czarina loves you
for that so once you have that you can
do whatever the [ __ ] he wanted it oh
yeah and like I never want to like he
took full of a divorce
of course yeah the kids were his meal
ticket basically in a way it might now
that you mentioned it yeah um he might
not have done anything bad to the kids
because that like you said that was me
if he did something bad to know you lost
everything then yeah because if your mom
nobody [ __ ] about the kids are the
source of his power
yeah so of course the kids have to love
him so I imagine he [ __ ] entertained
the shadows kids that's what they say oh
yeah and like I said they never said he
did nothing bad to them and it's like
the second dose yeah that might have
been cuz they were naive and [ __ ] but I
think those kids turn on him he's out of
the palace yeah so that's what he has to
do yeah yeah now it should be said that
you know even though the czarina was all
as if the kids were all into him they
called him their friend and stuff like
that now other family members not so
jazzed about his presence they thought
it was weird that like he was allowed to
hang out with the girls
it was weird um you know when they were
teenagers he's not that he's like oh
he's in there like caressing them and
it's like it's strange and it's
inappropriate
so a lot of things didn't like it well
you know what he's doing
yeah he's doing that but he's not
knocking that down because that would of
course Tsar Nicholas and the wife you
know this arena would come after him
yeah so yeah of course he's loving on
all right he's not doing he's not
transgressing because if you do that
then you lose access yeah because they
don't really like get them yeah right
right okay well they'd have you killed
you need her or you need these kids to
approve of you because if they dump then
you can't rape the servants and yes
cruise arena whether he was okay like
I'm nothing he was good I'm not really
sure if he was like I sure believe that
he was like raping the servants in 92 I
don't know if he was having an affair
with this arena or not rumors about that
have circulated but just everything that
I have read about her personality about
her relationship with the Czar and stuff
like that I'm not sure that she would
have gone to that extent of like having
sex with him but it could be but I'm not
saying that he's doing that with
everyone else though remember that movie
that we saw the favorite yeah I have a
feeling a great movie I had I have a
feeling that a lot of the royal families
okay we're kind of what you call
swingers true okay it wouldn't surprise
me okay I'm not saying this is it I'm
not saying that this happened okay
I'm start banging on all cylinders no it
would not surprise me if one of the
reasons why Rasputin was able to get it
with this [ __ ] he got away with could've
been desire Nicholas might have been a
little bit bisexual I'm just gonna say
it
well sure cuz you know Tom so maybe
there was some [ __ ] going on there that
we don't know about yeah I mean that's
the thing it's like yeah we can
speculate all day long Ron it's like you
know we weren't there like no one was
there behind closed doors there might
abroad kind of remember that program we
saw what the guy was taking taken
advantage of
Mormons oh yeah yeah not only Weezy he'd
not only did he abduct the daughter and
screw the wife she was [ __ ] around
with the husband oh my god what the [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh that was like I can't really
good is Netflix could it be that
Rasputin actually put the moves on Tsar
Nicholas and actually had control over
Tsar's our Nicholas although I feel like
he had less control over Nicholas than
he did over Alexandra like Nicholas
would see here's the thing I think in
later years and particularly in a lot of
propaganda that was written later on
about Rasputin that it's like oh he's
the one that caused the downfall the
room and I think he was like telling
them what to do I don't think he had as
much influence as he's generally given
credit for because honestly the the
Russian aristocracy was crumbling yeah
so he was just taking advantage of a
[ __ ] aristocracy heart in it sure I
don't think it was like a really big
part it was more like a parasite because
Nicholas um you know particularly after
a few years he was kind of like yeah I'm
just gonna go over here and you guys do
whatever like he kind of I feel like he
kept her ass beating around because it
made his wife happy yeah because she
liked him and she believed in him I
don't think Nicholas was as suckered by
them as she was or as enamoured of him
and yes he would listen to Rasputin
suggestions but sometimes he didn't
yeah but Rasputin didn't end the
Romanovs the Romanovs were on their way
out that's I think that's giving him
entirely
yeah he was like just part of the old
because from the scene during that what
was going what really got rid of the
Roman officers World War one yeah they
they never recovered from yeah but I
yeah I definitely do think like I said I
don't think because I have seen some I
was watching some documentaries about
him that were like you know trying to
paint him in the worst light possible
and then some that were just like oh he
wasn't so bad or anything like that um I
think he was kind of a she
he was an opportunist but I don't think
I I don't think he was you know the
person that caused the whole downfall of
the line or anything like I think that
would have happened anyway maybe it was
World War one and the coup the coup de
Gras was the Bolshevik Revolution yeah
the Bolsheviks got rise of communism
creation of the Soviet Union that's
that's just the new era came yeah and
like it wasn't better really well well
kinda it's almost like it was a lateral
move the Soviet era was [ __ ] bloody
and at its best it was boring if you
talk to X Soviet citizens you know we
came I'm from I'm a cold war-era guy so
the union was [ __ ] boring really
that's you know it was a boring [ __ ]
place you couldn't be hard to get genes
it was it was hard to get jammed up I
wouldn't get good music I remember
looking boring yeah like I said it's
it's almost kind of like going from the
Imperial period to like the Soviet
period was like a lateral move yeah they
wanted it to be better it just wasn't
better [ __ ] boring it was just it was
just as bad you know not cool but yeah
so like I said do I think Rasputin
caused the downfall no I think that
would have happened anyway like I said
the [ __ ] was crumbling even before he
got there like you know the country was
kind of an upheaval and [ __ ] like that
so I don't think he had that much
influence over their decisions and Tsar
Nicholas had not was not known for
making really sharp decisions prior to
him arriving Pro the problem with
monarchy is that you have most of the
time average guys inheriting too much
power or crazy people crazy inherited
madness yeah and Nicholas was I think
would have been
have been just been under normal
circumstances would have been just a
very mundane dude like I said working at
the gas he was at least self-aware
enough to know that he didn't want to do
that he just kind of got into it because
he was the guy it's like he was the next
one in line and he had to do it yeah he
didn't want to do it he said that yeah
and he wasn't good at it
nobody thought he was good at it right
poor Nicholas you know I mean when you
think about I feel kind of bad for him a
gigantic country that was poor yes a
very backwards almost medieval people
and you're trying to make this big
[ __ ] [ __ ] in into something
that worked and it just it's that era of
Russia's it was just nothing it was just
not was just wasn't a modern country
wasn't in the modern era yet and it
didn't come into the modern era really
until the 90s and yeah some may say that
it's still not modern but my heart goes
out to the Russians the Russians were a
hard-working people they've been through
hell look at their [ __ ] history yeah
they're the heart conan's yeah the thing
is it's like I don't know it's like I
say I feel bad for Tsar Nicholas in a
way I do but in a way I don't because by
all accounts even though he seemed yes
he loved his wife yes he loved his
children but he was also a very
autocratic ruler he believed that you
know I have the divine right to do this
on the other he had like a really
horrible like secret police that [ __ ]
murdered people you know and [ __ ] like
that so it you know it's kind of a thing
where I feel bad cuz they all got gunned
down and that sucks but you know for the
kids mostly but I don't know it's it's
kind of a hard thing because there was
nothing wrong like I said there's nobody
no heroes in this there's no if you ask
me there was really nothing wrong with
the Romanovs the Roman officer just did
the wrong place at the wrong time and
they think about how could you lead a
nation like that you know I mean there
wasn't much of a nation as we know it
and it was still medieval really
yeah really they were in charge of a
city or two yeah that's kind of I don't
even know how you would begin to rule
something like a landmass that's that
large without technology and you're just
in one pallet yeah with no technology no
no telecommunications so I keep maybe we
could do it now but not that but back
then what the [ __ ] it's like geez you'd
make a law and it would take like
[ __ ] three months for it to get any
when you think about the rise of the
Bolsheviks and the killing of the
[ __ ] royal family was more symbolic
than it was actual it was because the
Bolsheviks could have just risen to
power and sidestepped that's what they
were gonna do they weren't going to kill
because there's just the wrong I was
really weren't important at that point
anyway yeah they were going to kill I
didn't have a reach yeah true
hey but like I said that that's
something that evolved over the course
because they totally weren't going to at
first they were just gonna like exile
them or like a prison or whatever and
then it's just kind of exiled into like
the horrible bloodbath that ended but
let's actually lips we're probably at
the halfway point right now yeah let's
take a break so let's take a break right
now when we come back we will talk a
little bit more about Rasputin and what
happened to him and also what happened
to the Romanov family it wasn't good
spoiler alert
so the faceless villain a collection of
the eeriest
unsolved murders of the 20th century vol
2 includes cases spanning the years from
1960 through 1979 featuring such
infamous crimes as the triple homicide
at Lake Bodom the family Massacre known
as the good heart murders the serial
killings of the Zodiac Bible John Jack
the stripper and the freeway phantom the
slaughter of dozens of women and girls
along the highway of tears and the Texas
killing fields and the mysterious death
of suspected spy the is doll woman along
with dozens of other fascinating and
horrifying accounts by it now from
Amazon in print Kindle or audiobook
format
what are you doing what are you doing
you're so weird
[Laughter]
look at how funny why did you fall
asleep Lee good did you fall asleep like
that you did are you sleeping
no okay sorry I those are her two sticks
y'all because she chews on anything
metal like she chews on microphones she
chews on computer cords or power cords
so I bought her these little sticks that
hang up on them
chewy they do work but she still chews
on [ __ ] she's not supposed to yeah okay
yeah I want to interrupt you that
[Music]
I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and declared at the end
of the day at this house is very much
tortured and will continue to be honored
there a long time okay so we're back now
at this point Rasputin is apparently
talking to his friend who is a monk
named Iliad or that wasn't actually his
real name it was like his monk name or
whatever I guess that's like your hip
hop it's a foreign name I guess so
allegedly he says to his friend the monk
that he has kissed the zarina right
he didn't say he had sex with her he
said he kissed her so the monk is like
nah bro making that [ __ ] up
so then Rasputin like produces all these
letters that's like look look at these
love letters that we've read now are
these real love letters are they forged
who [ __ ] knows he couldn't read
evidently right but I don't know I don't
know where they came from I don't know
somebody else you know wrote them or
what so he shows them to the monk and
the monk is like you know you are
supposed to be a holy figure you're a
religious person once you knock all this
[ __ ] off right um you know try to tell
me check himself yeah cool with the
lingo on this show you [ __ ] around
with the czarina and they they gonna
wreck you you know so then later on like
some more alleged charges of yet another
attempted rape come to light
apparently Rasputin had tried to rape a
nun
so we wish him boundaries he's pushing
boundaries you got rid of it that's one
way Oh knock that [ __ ] down that's
that's nice leave that sexy habit cheese
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's about
that's probably what he thought too sure
but yeah so those charges kind
you know got out into the public a
little bit and at this point at least
the Czar and czarina were like okay well
maybe we need to like go over here and
like from Rasputin because this is not
good associated with this kind of thing
now for about a year they kind of like
stay at arm's length they're like you
stay over there with your nun raping and
we will just stay over here with our
crumbling aristocracy thing that we're
doing now
it wasn't until late 1912 that Rasputin
was able to re-enter the lives of the
Romanovs and that was because Alexei had
another episode apparently they were
going on this they were going on
vacation and he suffered some kind of it
was a rowing accident and he like
started bleeding uncontrollably then
they had to like take him back to the
house and they were like in the carriage
and it was bumping him around and he was
like flipping he was like in horrible
agony and he actually was starting to
say [ __ ] about it you know it's okay if
I die it's like I can't take the pain
anymore and all this other kind of stuff
so in desperation they called Rasputin
back to tend to the boy
at which point allegedly the boy again
stopped bleeding
hmm so we don't know like Rasputin
somehow did something that made
everything okay again so like it's only
he knew something so yeah he had some
kind of folk he did I mean there was
yeah I mean they for real thought that
he that their kid was dying yeah and
then as much as they you know we're
trying to not associate themselves with
Rasputin at least public it's like I
said they were already unpopular they
didn't want to be associated with this
dude that was like running around like a
crazy person
because there are other accounts that
you know he would like run out in the
street and like say you'd possessed by
demons or whatever like [ __ ] like that
you know was he proud to add to his
[ __ ] his street cred so he was like a
crazy you know look I can get possessed
by a demon and that can exorcise myself
and everyone could see the shittest
power yeah but you do it of course when
you're drunk so you know so evidently
they call Rasputin back and he kind of
fixes it um but still bizarre is kind of
like okay well let's kind of keep this
on the down-low because he doesn't have
the best reputation and we don't have
the best reputation so we don't want to
be like guilt by association um so you
know awesome
but then Rasputin allegedly goes around
with stories about oh well I can have
sex with his arena like whatever I want
to you know I mean now even at this
point Alexandra was still inclined to
support him I mean she she seemed to
genuinely think that he was a saint that
he had mystical powers I mean she would
say like well you know Saints have
always been reviled you know everyone
always hated them so this is just
another case of that um you know and and
[ __ ] like that so there was this whole
kind of situation yeah mystical powers
over that ass perhaps yes because I
think he's playing with fire if you ask
me well because I can see this [ __ ]
coming you know I mean I'm a man of you
know nearly fifty years of age and I can
see where this shows go but I would have
known I would have known I could have
seen where this [ __ ] was coming okay I
don't understand why man like I think he
pride knew where I was going but of
course yes I live it up he did because
he actually did make a prophecy about it
that he knew he was going to die and he
thought that the whole Romanov family
was gonna die oh yeah you know so he
kind of knew what his score was I think
maybe he was just trying to get it all
in there but I think he literally was
probably a crazy person
yeah but he wasn't so crazy he couldn't
see well he wasn't dumb and crazy or not
meet mutilates
if he could see what was happening he
knew this country was going to [ __ ]
and the royal family was he could play
with them and that he would eventually
be killed you know well and the thing
about and this is really sad because he
couldn't he couldn't he couldn't stand
the temptation though yeah he had to
play with it yeah but one thing that's
interesting is that Pierre Gilliard I
think his name is he was like a tutor
for all the for the room and off
children and he knew Rasputin quite well
and he said that you know the Tsar
didn't really what didn't really approve
of having rest feeding around but he
felt like if he sent him away then the
czarina would blame him with Alexei died
right so there was that [ __ ]
happening yeah so then as you said World
War one breaks out in 1914 now
interestingly the same day that Franz
Ferdinand was assassinated which was one
of the many things that led to World War
one breaking yeah some people might say
why did world will want to happen was it
nationalism
no it wasn't they'll tell you
nationalism started World War one what
really started World War one was mutual
defense pacts you know I mean they had
all these pacts and agreements if you
could attacked will stand behind you so
all's it took was one bad thing to
happen and all these mutual defense pact
would kick in and they all started
fighting each other so it wasn't
nationalism really
we're like globalism well see the thing
about well the thing about any kind of
historical incident you know because
even when you learn about World War II
like Oh Franz Ferdinand's assassination
and that was like a big thing but it's
never just one thing I mean sometimes
it's one thing that's just like the
straw that broke the camel's back there
was all the [ __ ] I was leading up to it
and I think that was the case in this
but what I was gonna say mutual defense
pacts mutual defense pact or was like a
powder keg nut I mean once they hit all
agreed to back one another solid took
was one thing and no one could back out
now I had to fight each other
oh good well what I was gonna say was
that the same day that Fran that Franz
Ferdinand was assassinated someone
attempted to assassinate Rasputin yeah
now this was a prostitute she didn't
have a nose because my parent Lee what
no like apparently one of her clients
quote had cut her nose off damn for some
[ __ ] did something bad because dudes
are the best bad no she did it was back
in the day that's how you dealt with
[ __ ] back in the day we don't know the
people involved she might have bit
somebody or did something bad so nobody
deserves to get their [ __ ] know was
kind of extended served an Ed bond dear
bTW no one deserves anything just [ __ ]
happen but I'm just saying so she didn't
have a nose so somebody paid her to
assassinate Rasputin now apparently she
goes up to him she needed money and well
she's a prostitute yeah without a nose
nobody said hey you want to like kill
the shoot shoot yeah right yeah you're
gonna give me how she maybe she buy a
fake nose with it now she goes and he
sees her like coming to each like she
goes him waits by his church or whatever
and then he comes out and he sees her
standing over there and she's like
looking at him and then she comes up to
him and just stabbed so [ __ ] she stabbed
him in this stomach a bunch of times and
then reached her hand into his stomach
and pulled his intestines oh no [ __ ]
she's hardcore [ __ ] this newest woman is
a hero
well almost because he didn't die she's
a hero no this shouldn't murder
cheston's out yeah and yet and this is
another thing that contributes to his
mystique of like the mannequin dies he
gets his he gets [ __ ] stabbed
multiple times she was is he abdomen and
pulls into his intestines and he lived
she must have some clean ass hands
because cuz yeah clean
maybe his insides were already so
infected like they were just like oh
another one alright whatever because he
was a dirty [ __ ]
he was probably immune to it yeah yeah
see so he was thinking ahead he's like
you know what if I never bathe and never
like wash any of the dirt wrong ass
immunities I don't have a really strong
immune system so yeah
Dudley's not that dumb yeah so she pulls
his intestines out but he survives
however he is in the hospital
convalescing yeah during the time when
czar nicholas really could have used
some words of wisdom about what we
should do about the outbreak of World
War 1 now one thing that Rasputin did
tell the Czar was that if Russia goes to
war it will be the end of the monarchy
of the Romanovs and of Russian
institutions now he actually advised
Nicholas to not go to war but Nicholas
did not listen I think I would have
[ __ ] not gone to war actually it
really didn't go so well for Russia it
didn't go so well so that's what a lot
of people have said it's like maybe he
shoulda listened to Rasputin in history
would have been different but he did not
listen to Rasputin in this situation
this was probably like the first time he
didn't really listen to his counsel
so obviously is everyone who studied
World War one knows robo-one was really
really not good for Russia millions and
millions of people died I'm not sure how
many Russians died in that though he's a
million at least a million at least okay
maybe more I'm not sure I never really
studied it from their point of view yeah
yeah well they thought that it wasn't
going to drag on as long as it did I
don't think and always gonna be a quick
war yeah I don't think anyone expected
it to go on as long as it went on um so
you know so many deaths stuff like that
and at this stage like I said the
Romanovs were already fairly unpopular
and
at this stage particularly the czarina
became suspect because she was German
people thought she was a spy
also people didn't like her association
with Rasputin because he had a very bad
reputation also so there was this whole
thing going and there was this whole
thing brewing about the imperial family
and we need to do something about that
so because of all this [ __ ] that was
going on about like I said the czarina
being German and about her you know
supposedly being influenced too much by
Rasputin who a lot of the people whether
they were you know just regular people
or whether they were nobles really
didn't like the fact that this peasant
from Siberia who they considered to be
like a crazy sexual deviant was kind of
like running the country whether he was
or not I doubt it but that was wrong
that was the the oppression that they
wanted to give so there was a lot of
like dissension and like we need to get
rid of this dude now this one politician
is name was vladimir Hershkovitz and he
gets up in front of the duma which is
like the legislative body which was
something that Tsar Nicholas had
established grudgingly he didn't really
believe in democracy he didn't really
think that it would work and he didn't
want to do that but you know since it
was I guess it was a lot of popular
support so he finally was just like fine
even though I think I have godlike
British rule why not
so purge cabbage stands up and says you
know this guy is pretty much controlling
the government we need to take him out
and he had a lot of popular support for
that opinion so there is a prince named
Felix Yusupov and he decides to take it
upon himself to assassinate Rasputin
yeah so he's actually the husband of
Nicholas's niece yeah yeah I think is
how that family thing goes so his yes so
the niece was named Irina Alexandrovna
drew I think is if I remember this is he
this guy's vaguely millet
area I think he did some military stuff
before this uh perhaps I think it's just
been a long time you know since I've
details yes so he gets together with
Grand Duke named Dmitri Pavlovich who
was actually a cousin of Nicholas Czar
Nicholas and they're like okay well
we're gonna take respite now now the
story goes and like I said sources
differ on this I'm not sure how
historically accurate his story goes
that Yusupov says okay well I know that
he has a thing for my wife who is arena
who was suppose I've seen pictures of
her she was very beautiful yeah all the
Romanovs actually were they were all
good-looking people yeah so he's like so
I'm gonna invite him to like a party you
know on the pretense of like meeting her
something like that like I said this is
how the story goes so they invite him to
this party they haven't set up there's
like nobody in this basement but the
dining rooms all set up as though there
has been a party and he's like he tells
Rasputin he's like oh well she's
upstairs like you know saying goodbye to
her guests or whatever we'll just like
stay down here and like will eat and
drink wait for her to come down so
evidently they have like a whole bunch
of little cakes or petit fours or
whatever and these were all laced with
cyanide so they sit Rasputin down
Rasputin News obviously never one to
turn down free dessert as you know why
would you so he starts chowing down on
the [ __ ] now even though there was
reportedly enough cyanide in these cakes
to kill at least three men he just keeps
eating them and eating them it is happy
as a pig in [ __ ] and he and nothing
seems to be happening so the two
conspirators like will [ __ ] okay let's
give him some wine then so they give him
this Madeira wine which is also laced
with cyanide
apparently he drinks three glasses of
the [ __ ] also has no effect other than
him getting a little bit drunker I'm
calling [ __ ] on this yeah good okay
so at this stage they're like watching
him and they're just like watching him
in a maze
they're like we have given him enough
poison to kill several horses and a
whale and he's still sitting there
eating and drinking like nothing is
happening so finally they're just like
let's just shoot him can't build a
resistance society so I'm thinking that
this is some kind of some kind of a
legend the shooting that's a legend but
yeah I think this is I think it's kind
of you cannot build a resistant to
cyanide yeah cyanides kills your [ __ ]
ass yeah okay so I think this is
overblown this might be like for real he
was shot and he was thrown in the river
they probably did give him some cyanide
them maybe they did but maybe it wasn't
as much as much as they're saying right
but in their accounts they're saying
look we gave him enough to kill several
men he's still acted like it didn't do
anything so we decided okay [ __ ] it
we're just gonna shoot him I would
believe the story if you could build up
a resistance to cyanide and I've Ray I
haven't seen any any evidence that you
can build up a resistance to cyanide
yeah you eat cyanide you start to
suffocate you breathe yeah not that one
that one's bad but so yeah supposedly
what happened next was that so said so
they decided to shoot him so he points a
revolver Rasputin Rasputin reportedly
gets up and just like looks at him and
just stands there he doesn't attempt to
run he doesn't it he just looks there
and he's not like I've not you know
anything so he shoots him in the chest
Rasputin falls down in the ground now
after a few minutes this is just like a
horror movie you so he goes over there
and kind of leans over him to make sure
he's dead and rasputin's eyes open and
he grabs him like by the throat and it
starts fighting and then the guy's like
[ __ ] and then later he runs away and
like he runs it like the [ __ ] is still
alive we poison the [ __ ] I'm we shot him
and he's still alive
now could you find any evidence about
what kind of pistol this was with the
calibers okay I can explain that okay
there were a lot of weak calibers during
this era your average your average
caliber
during this era this on par with like
what you would know today is 32 acp
which is a very very light caliber you
could absorb several hits of 32 acp okay
that the wound the wound profile is very
similar to an icepick you know I mean it
doesn't [ __ ] up a lot of flesh
it's just penetration if it's not really
in the right spot it doesn't damage a
lot of tissue you know so you can take
it so maybe he was shot some kind of a
Russian 3-ball
yes there were Russian 38 revolvers and
30 caliber type revolvers and 35 s that
had they had kind of ballistic profiles
of something like 32 that's probably
what he got hit with you could survive
that bullet print shot placement would
be of paramount importance with a weak
caliber like that so go ahead
yeah that's not that unbelievable so
apparently so like I said in a horror
movie like he immediately gets shot he
gets back up cuz they're like looking at
him for a while and there's like okay
he's dead but then I lean over but he's
like so then they run upstairs no like
freaking out and everything like that
then Rasputin gets up and runs out the
door and he's out in the courtyard so
they run after him and then they shoot
his ass again now this time they shoot
him like right in the [ __ ] forehead
at which point he falls to the ground
they kind of like take him they wrap him
up in a thing they take him to a bridge
and throw him off into a river which was
like covered it with ice but there was
like a fishing hole so they threw him in
the frame and the frozen ice now a
couple like a day or two later they
finally find
Rasputin's body and yes he is finally
dead um see here's the thing I saw two
different documentaries about this and
like I said different sources and stuff
like that one source said that the
autopsy report said that the cause of
death was the gunshot in the forehead
right the other one said that the
autopsy report said that the cause of
death was drowning
meaning that he was still
alive when he was thrown into the water
that's plausible which is plausible
might have been by be shot in the head
with a small caliber bullet and be
rendered unconscious in a coma fall into
the water and breathe in some water yeah
very very plausible so in a lovers of
those days were weak by today's
standards yeah so yeah so like I said
you know there there are so many like
legends or any like the man that
couldn't dies if I think even one like
[ __ ] documentary I saw brows about
Rasputin was called the man just because
it Chuck's it because it's like poison
it gunshots and [ __ ] drowning or
whatever but I you know I don't know
it's he was certainly stubborn and was
certainly a badass I mean as far as I
know he was shot at least three times
I'm pretty sure that both that most of
the sources I saw said the autopsy
report said he can at least three
gunshots even though some sources say
that it was more there's no there's
there's nothing about what gun it was
well I don't know it yeah and see you
didn't see that
no the revolt the standard revolver of
that time was a Mosin Nagant revolver it
was a gas check revolver powerlevel was
around like 38 special that's
understandable but the aristocracy would
have carried it probably more Western
type guns that were harder to get you
know I mean more you know more expensive
more elite they'd probably have been
small you're probably talking about
stuff like 32 acp 25 acp and hell yeah
you could take a chance shot of 28 25
acp and go into a coma yeah breathe in
some water yeah I mean like you said it
might have been a case where maybe they
gave him some poison but it wasn't that
much that much yeah they may be shot him
three or four times but but it wasn't
enough to kill him yes round because the
you know the aristocrats would have had
foreign guns from Western Europe in the
United States and they would have been
things like 32 ACP and [ __ ] 25 ACP you
know that's a rich boy gun for the
Russians probably in there they're
pretty weak yeah so yeah like I said
sounds well well that it combined with
like you know the
prostitutes stab you pulling his
intestines out like in 1914 I mean he
was obviously a stubborn [ __ ]
who didn't want to die a lot of taking a
shot it's just willpower if you're
pissed off you can take pretty
significant come to I think that that's
kind of one of the hard things to
because Rasputin is such a almost a
mythical figure at this point so I feel
like some of the [ __ ] around his death
has been exaggerated
like I said yes it was hard to kill him
you know yes they had to shoot him a
bunch of times whether or not they
poison him I don't know but I think that
like adds to his mystique and it
definitely added his mystique in the
years following his death which was in
nineteen late 1916 if I didn't mention
it because I think people even then
thought that he had some kind of magic
powers I wouldn't say they were magical
powers I believe he did probably
ingesting poison I think he did survive
a couple of bullet wounds but if you if
you really look at the details a lot of
being shot is psychological and how you
react to it you know I mean there's a
lot of studies that will prove that to
you if you're being shot by smaller
calibers yeah you can absorb them sure
you're hurt yeah you might die of
infection you might die a blood loss but
it might take a long time you know what
I mean yeah so I'm saying is plausible
yeah what they're saying about respite
is probably possible well yeah I mean
obviously risible because that happened
yeah it's just that I think in later
years his mystique has grown up to the
point where people are exaggerating
things to make it look like he gives
some kind of superhuman yeah but she
obviously wasn't he wasn't superhuman he
wasn't being shot with say like 357
Magnum he wasn't being shot with locust
hanging out right you know these were
more sedate antique cartridges that he's
being hit with so yeah I wouldn't doubt
it yeah soon as I said Rasputin is
assassinated finally in December of 1916
now in February of 1970
along comes the Russian Revolution and
the Romanov family is pretty much you
know relieved of their thromes
they abdicate their Tsar Nicholas
abdicates his throne now by all accounts
he was actually kind of relieved about
this because like I said he wasn't super
jazzed about beings are so they were
just like well you know you're not
Tsar anymore you're just Nicholas
Romanov now and you're just they sent
them off to like house arrest now at
this point as I said the Bolsheviks were
it was in their interest to keep the
family alive because they still had a
lot of supporters um they didn't want to
look like the bad guys and like having
them you know having them killed and
stuff like that so they actually kept
them alive for for a little while they
just moved them around to like from to
various locations they said even in when
they first sent them to their the first
place that they went to they said
actually the guards were pretty friendly
toward them you know they kind of made
friends with them and like the Romanovs
seemed like they were adapting well to
the new lifestyle even though they
couldn't really go out or anything like
that I mean it wasn't a prison they were
just arraigned custody
yeah there was in custody like they were
in like a nice place but they just
couldn't really leave so it was that
type of thing however as time went on
the Bolsheviks started to think you know
we can't have them around because what
if there are still Tsar as lawyers
loyalists around as their work which
there were um not so much in
Ekaterinburg where they were eventually
sent and where they were eventually
executed that was a pretty much
Bolshevik stronghold but you know they
still had enough supporters around that
they were reluctant to do anything that
would make them look like you're make
them into murderers is you know the
thing that is so the first place they
were sent to it was like like I said it
wasn't a prison it was a palace it was
called and
please forgive me if I butcher the
Russian but it's called the circus ello
I guess is what it's called okay so they
sent them there that was east of the
Ural Mountains they actually had quite a
good time there
Nicolas seemed to like relax a lot he's
a clue but I'm too bizarre anymore they
let him kind of run around outside you
know they they still had their staff
they still had their maids and
attendants and things like that they
kept all their personal possession you
probably thought was gonna go down the
way it went down with the British family
[Music]
yeah well initially um they were led to
believe and they thought that they would
actually just be exiled out of the
country and they would be allowed to go
live with King George the fifth who was
their cousin and they would go to live
with him in Britain um or it would be
allowed to go to their summer estate
which was in the Crimea so they weren't
particularly concerned
like I said they didn't have any
stresses anymore that you know they
weren't ruling the [ __ ] so you know
everything was fine and as I said the
kids seemed to be into it
perm all accounts them like I was to was
saying about Anastacio before since she
was the one that kind of got a lot more
famous later on because of people
claiming to be her in later years yeah
they were claiming to be her yeah on
Geraldo
things I've grown up me this is on Carl
I am anastasiya hilarious I mean by all
accounts she was she was a very funny
child she was a prankster
good-looking look at the photograph
they're all beautiful they're um and I
think that was
that's really why that's why everyone
was claiming to be honest as you well
known I think that was kind of the
reason to why this story like resonate
so suddenly feels like they look at all
these little good-looking little kids
yeah I mean you know most of weren't
little kids they were teenagers
teenagers down to like what 79 yeah I
think
anastacio was 16 years
I've seen so many pictures over the
years I remember how old were you and
she was about 16 when she when she was
killed
yeah 16 or 17 I can't remember so as I
said at first the Romanovs were actually
treated pretty well you know they were
under house arrest essentially they were
at a palace and bottle block the guard
that was kind of in charge of their care
was pretty sympathetic toward them you
know and wasn't mean to them or anything
like that however they eventually ended
up getting sent to this place called a
potty of house in Ekaterinburg which was
a very as I said before a very anti
Czarist very strong communist stronghold
um however when they moved their first
still they still had the same fine
treatment they still had their you know
servants and everything like that but
then the Bolsheviks in the area assigned
another guard to look after them and
this guy was named yeah coffee offski
this guy was not sympathetic to the
Romanov family at all
and he basically he didn't treat them
badly he just maintained a very like
hands-off kind of like you know you're
my prisoner today he was very distant
and professional and he kind of like
stopped the other guards from like
fraternizing with them he like basically
cracked down right and he's like if this
is very rural basic institutional well
and ironically the the former Tsar
Nicholas actually kind of liked this guy
even though this was the guy that was
gonna be in charge of their execution
boiler alert guess he respected his
professionalism I suppose yeah I think
that's what it was so by all accounts
the last people to see the Romanovs
alive were actually for cleaning women
and they came in to clean the house
prior to the Hicks I don't know why they
were cleaning it prior to the execution
maybe was just a cleaning that they were
doing anyway
but these were for cleaning women and
they came in and they were talking about
I mean the Romanovs had no idea that
they were going to be assassinated they
were pretty much like oh we're just
being held here for our safety because
you know we're unpopular we're gonna be
sent into exile it'll all be fine she
said they were all in good spirits you
know they were acting totally normal
you know they were getting bored because
they were kind of like confined and
stuff like that but other than that they
seem to have no clue of their imminent
demise yeah so so these four women were
thought to be the last civilians to have
seen them alive now on July 16th there
was a telegram that arrived in Moscow
and that was addressed to Lenin and said
okay well we've decided that we're going
to kill the whole family because we
can't have them around Jinyu just in
case of sympathizers or whatever yeah
and they were afraid that if they exiled
them that later on people would say well
we can get rid of these communists and
bring the royal family back so they
wanted to make sure that there was that
this is a point of no return
yeah we're gone and that's it you know
so so the decision was made evidently
Lenin said it was okay and Bill plus it
was like a couple of different factions
the red and the white and they were
fighting in the city so they were like
okay well they're getting too much
trouble at this point so let's just
liquidate them yeah so evidently the
whole family are woken up about 1:30 in
the morning and are told to go down to
the cellar there are a bunch of a chairs
against the wall yeah and they just told
us they said you're being moved here for
your own safety because of all these
like and people fighting and stuff like
that so you know just sit here and wait
and then before they could even like
react to whatever was going on everyone
started opening fire
yeah jumped in there with guns and shot
them all yeah um a hundred and three
shots that's what I heard 103 shots now
interestingly here's the
here's the creepy part now they shot
Nicolas first I believe they just shot
him in the head they did chest shots and
then it had jobs like at the end to make
sure but when they shot the girls they
shot them in the chest first but
apparently they didn't die right away
because what they had done I mean they
all had course it's on like you did at
the time but they had taken like a lot
of the crown jewels and stuff like that
it had sewn them like into their corsets
and apparently this acted like a
bulletproof vest some extent so when
they were like shot in the chest like it
knocked them down but it didn't kill
them so later on like the guards
apparently went back shot them in the
head like hit them with rifle butts or
with the bayonets or whatever to make
sure they were all dead you know and
apparently the room was like full of
smoke and there was all screaming and
all this other kind of [ __ ] I'm actually
gonna call [ __ ] on that because what
they would have used they would be used
moseying that got rifles to do this
which is 76 - by 54r that's a carcass
like set like kind of like 30.6 there's
nothing you could you could sew into a
course it to absorb that I'm just saying
that's part that's death myth if you ask
me they were [ __ ] just guns down with
a major caliber out of bolt-action
rifles and we're just cut to ribbons you
know that's what that's all i'ma tell
you happened cuz I could imagine it you
know what I mean they were and they're
probably they were probably a lot of
shots but they pride in like you said
what do you think was 173 I guarantee
that was over a period of time because
you couldn't work those bolt-action they
said it took about 20 minutes yeah you
couldn't work that couldn't work those
bolt actions that fast I mean according
to people that depend on how many guys
there they probably loaded a couple
times they would just shoot him to
pieces after they were dead yeah that's
probably what was real and I can't make
sure that they were dead and I have a
picture here and I'll show it like there
is a picture of the room yeah the whole
thing kind of cleaned and stuff but the
whole thing about having jewels crown
jewels hidden inside the course that's
active isn't that stat sounds like an
embellishment to me because I can
imagine that you can't stop that round
it's a major rifle round and that's what
that's what the Bolsheviks were using I
believe at that time so I was like 1880s
that that came out that's what they
would have used yeah as a [ __ ] big
rifle round man go through 30 people I
mean it's a that's a major caliber rifle
like 30 yeah like 30 out six really and
I mean it should be noted too that it
wasn't just the room on our family that
were killed it well so there are
attendants it was their physician it was
like their maids their attendants and
from from some sources that I read it's
like these are people that chose to
accompany them when they went into exile
yeah and they were gunned down as well
loyal supporters so it ended up being 11
people killed that would have been
personal friends and loyal supporters
yeah it's a sad story it is if you ask
me I mean even if they did shitty things
like those kids didn't deserve and if
you ask me the Romanovs really
especially the kids they did nothing to
really deserve all this and you didn't
have to kill them their murders were
symbolic really you know I mean they
could have exiled him yeah well that's
what they were gonna do and in the end
they wanted to make sure the rest of
people had no hope yeah that the
Bolsheviks wanted dude I mean they did
not want to go back to a monarchy I
think it worked against him the Soviet
Union probably in Russia pride of it
better off 2-digit to do what England
did which was to keep their royal family
as like a historical you know talk about
like a historical or like a symbolic
like a symbolic yeah well it's kind of
like a memoir of the past but so be even
was so Marxist in their way of [ __ ]
erasing history that they killed these
people really for nothing the Soviet
Union probably and Russia President
better off if they just retired him yeah
well and it seems like they could have
done that because even though I mean and
now we know they they did they gunned
them all down in that cellar like I said
the room and our family and all their
attendance their physician
and everything like that they killed
them all and then they loaded them all
on a truck and they took them and they
buried them you know tried to burn the
bodies with sulfuric acid with fire [ __ ]
like that yeah they didn't know that
until much later on but the thing is is
that after that happened they knew that
there would still be some sympathizers
so what they would so what they would
say was that they only killed the Czar
yeah but that the wife and kids were
sent off to live in act to a secret
place when we can't tell you where they
are
so it seems dumb that they killed all of
those people and then still told people
that they were alive when they could
have just left them alive it's probably
because they've done what they said that
they probably done probably because
after they did it they realized it was
probably it was a mistake yeah cause
like I said it seemed like a last-minute
decision it's a sign of insecurity if
the Soviet Union and communism was so
great you wouldn't have to kill the
royal family you could have just you
know I mean animatic advocate and you'd
have been a few to have moral
superiority and you would have ruled as
a as as a communist government over the
new Empire that's really how they should
have done yeah like I said it it seems
like they were thinking super clear they
weren't thinking ahead it seems like a
decision that it was kind of made on the
spur of the moment the Soviet Union
during its early period that first 30
years of sucky chaos yeah yeah Stalin
clearly yeah the ship Stalin did you
just shoot you right there that they
they weren't thinking so so the thing is
because um you know the the incoming
communist government were so secretive
about what it ultimately happened to the
Romanovs
there were many many rumors swirling
that most of them had survived or had
gone into exile
probably the most popular ones too said
to have been survived were the two
youngest ones which were
anastacio and Alexei even though you'd
think I mean if Alexei had been shot he
would have bled to death almost
immediately because he had hemophilia
but um there were a lot of people that
came forward in later years saying that
they were Alexei and stuff like that
probably the most famous though was
people coming forward
saying they were honest hacia yeah and
that went on for many years and like I
said the book that I showed you guys at
the beginning of the show this came out
in the early 1970s I think 1974
something like that and at this point
none of the romanov bodies had been
found so they were speculating that some
of them could still be alive I mean
everyone was pretty sure that Nikolas
was dead because even the Bolshevik said
yeah we killed him but even they were
cagey about what had happened to the
rest of them they were embarrassed yes
they didn't want to see me that they
didn't mind saying that killed the
former Tsar right uh you know but they
didn't want to be seen as like killing
like a woman or girls and stuff so there
was a lot of so because they were so
secretive about it you know rumors
circulated for a long time that some of
them were still alive and in some ways
it gave people like hope that you know
maybe things weren't so bad maybe they
were still alive somewhere so that's I
think that's why a lot of and [ __ ] you
know later on the story of like all
these people that came forward saying
they were anastacio yeah it was even
they'd been into plays it was in a movie
like Ingrid Bergman was in a movie about
it they'd been [ __ ] made a [ __ ]
Disney cartoon about it called Anastacio
before they really knew what had
happened to her
all this is a testimony it's a testament
really to the weakness and insecurity of
the early Soviet empire that and
communism what would have been better
okay is to have the Communist revolution
and then twenty years later have the
Russian royal family come out publicly
and say how awesome communism and the
Soviet empire was that's really what
they should have done you know but they
were scared they couldn't let those
people live well let's remember if
something's good to like let it's kind
of good news just speak for itself
don't just yeah I feel like if you're
just like trying to [ __ ] on other yeah
people are trying to [ __ ] on like the
opposite thing to you then that's
probably the Russian fan that the
Russian royal family
actually week yeah I mean they weren't
great but well like I said this I think
this [ __ ] was probably inevitable I
don't I don't think Rasputin had that
big a thing I think this was just it was
huge a change yeah it was the way that
Harry was gonna go it's like those
people were just the ones that happened
to be around at the time they were in
the crossfire
that there yet they were just like kind
of subsumed under larger forces I think
that happened
yeah so the the only other thing I wanna
say is I want to kind of talk about this
one woman who for many many years and
like I said this book kind of went into
this too for many years was thought to
be a Nastasia now she was actually she
was fished out of a canal in Berlin in
1920 they didn't she didn't remember who
she was um she had a very thick Russian
accent she couldn't remember her name
she could remember what had happened to
her she had like a bunch of wounds like
her back was all [ __ ] like all cut up
and she had like all kind of like [ __ ]
up [ __ ] she had lost her memory so they
took her to a mental asylum and she was
there for a couple of years and claimed
that she had no memory of who she was or
what had happened to her now the story
goes that two years after this woman was
fished out of the canal this other woman
shows up at the mental asylum who was
Russian and she saw her and said that's
Anastacio and like bowed in front of her
and other kind of stuff now like I said
sources differ because some sources say
that she claimed to be a Nastasia but
most other sources say that she said she
didn't remember who she was and it was
just this other woman that came there
that said I think that's Anasazi and
then she was like oh maybe I am and for
you younger listeners this whole
anastacio thing is a cultural phenomenon
that goes way back it was a huge deal
okay you there are even Rolling Stones
lyrics about you know sympathy for the
devil's is a Nastasia screamed in pain
this goes all the way back to the 60s
and even the fifties that people were
hoping that anastacio had survived that
the two youngest there were people and
kept coming forward saying claiming to
be honest I was yet really all on the
back of a pretty photograph of the damn
girl you know I mean I hope that this
girl had survived it was it's it's a she
was a sad figure it's a tragic figure
yeah you know and it was hoped that she
had to live it was wishful thinking
which we know now because like at the
time and at the time this book was
written that first kind of got me into
this whole anastacio thing was that no
one knew no one knew what had happened
to her it's like and later on like one
of the guards that was supposedly at the
assassination said you know I loaded all
the bodies on the truck and then one of
the you know anastacio was still alive
yeah so I sent her away like to live
with another family names off ski and
stuff yeah there were all these rumors
that there were like sympathetic
Bolshevik type soldiers looking for her
- a bunch of mentally ill fakers and
[ __ ] like I said for a long time and and
it almost seemed because here's the
thing they found a mass grave in
actually amateur like archaeologists
found it in 1979 but no one really knew
about it until 1989 because like I said
remember if you remember if you're as
old as we are remember back in the old
days it was something they were very
secretive they didn't want to write you
they didn't want anybody knowing
anything so until like Gorbachev came
along in the whole glass nose thing and
everything like that yeah like they were
kind of keeping everything on the DL so
even though this mass grave had been
found which people thought was the
Romanovs had been found in the late
1970s nobody really knew about it until
1989 1991 and then they started doing
like testing and all these skeletons now
at this point in 1991 they determined
that the skeletons of the Czar were in
there the czarina were in there the two
oldest girls were in there and then
there was another female skeleton in
there which they said could either be
Maria or could be Anastacio but they
weren't really sure so since they
weren't sure people like oh that means
that Anastacio and alexei could still be
alive because they're not in the grave
they weren't in the grave with the other
ones
so you know so that kind of like fueled
it when that [ __ ] happened
however years later somebody else that
was like [ __ ] around another part of
like Siberia that was kind of near where
the other burial site was but not really
um
stumbled across two more skeletons and
these had kind of been burned with fire
also burned with sulfuric acid this was
a male and a female and later DNA test
because as I said this was the room and
I family they're related to many of the
other royal families of Europe so they
were easily able to get DNA from various
other Royals and they were able to
determine that the male skeleton was
definitely alexei and the female
skeleton was either Anastacio or maria
meaning that the one in the original
grave was either Anastacio maria
accounting for all of the Romanov family
yeah so it seems that all of them were
killed at the same time it just happened
that two of them the youngest ones
perhaps were buried in a different grave
perhaps because they had thrown them off
the truck and tried to burn them and
that's been a workout or then they went
to another grave I don't know why that
happened but they were buried in two
separate places but at this point in
case you didn't know as of 2008 DNA has
definitively proven that anastasi and
alexei have been found the entire room
in our family has been accounted for and
they were all assassinated on that night
in 1918 yeah so the sad thing though
about the woman that claimed to be a
Nastasia until her death and I was kind
of I was watching a documentary about
her earlier that day I'm not super sure
like I said she didn't really seem to
remember they were able to find out who
she was later on um they actually were
able to determine that she was actually
a woman named FranNet Francisca
Shannen shins cows cow I hope I'm
pronouncing that right she was polish
and that she'd been a factory worker now
what they think happened to her was that
this factory that she had been working
at she worked there with a bunch of her
friends and with her husband and that
this factory had been bombed or like had
been hit by a grenade and that she had
seen her husband die and seen a bunch of
her co-workers die and she had been
injured by the shrapnel and then had
subsequently lost her memory and had
thrown herself off a bridge or perhaps
lost her memory after throwing herself
off the bridge whatever so they're not
sure how culpable she could be about her
claiming to be a Nastasia because like I
said when she first arrived at the
mental hospital she said she didn't know
who she was and evidently it was only
this other person coming in the middle
hospital later that said oh I think
that's Anastasi and she's like oh maybe
so because she all these wounds and she
had obviously been through a traumatic
experience that she couldn't remember
and she was about the right age she
looked kind of like her
um and of course that would have been a
very romantic figure to adopt yeah
princess some members of the Romanov
family did come to see her and said yeah
that seems like her then again some of
the other was like some of their like
their French tutor and stuff said no
that's not her the personality she's not
like her um you know even though it's
been many years later he's like I don't
think that's her so there was like this
whole thing but she had enough
supporters within the extended family
that they you know gave her a pretty
nice life for the rest she like met a
history teacher in Virginia and married
him and they lived a very nice
comfortable life you know until she died
so I don't know I feel like I can't
begrudge her because maybe if she really
didn't remember who she was and all
these people were saying she was a
Nastasia and it was giving her life she
might have been like well maybe I am and
it's like you know maybe she didn't feel
that she was killed I mean she wasn't
coming down by Bolsheviks but nobody
knew that yeah and I mean this woman was
was dead long before they found out what
had really happened but like I said in
case
weren't aware yeah they have found the
bodies all of the Romanovs work it was a
shame you have Rushing's you have
Russians gunning down big figures from
their history there now lost forever
yeah you know ii mean the [ __ ] they
killed their royal family
most countries still retained in Europe
retain their royal families as monuments
to the past there was no reason why
communist Russia couldn't have done the
same thing I think that would have added
actually to calm this rush this oh yeah
family have yeah we're strong enough and
we're secure enough to know that we can
still keep these people around
everyone wants communism yeah yeah the
reason why they killed him is because
people would rather choose the choose
monarchy over communism communism was
not good yeah yeah we're old enough to
remember what the Soviet Union was
actually like in reality
I saw it crumble up is in the Army
during the time we our units used to
deal with the [ __ ] Soviet Army you
know we they were a trusted opponent and
a professional opponent you knew what
they were gonna do in some ways it was a
this is a different world it was the
most kind of like a better world when
you kind of had two Soviet Union you
could trust them to be your adversary
it's all gone now it's chaos now but
anyway yeah in 2000 actually the russian
orthodox church actually canonized the
Romanov family and they've all been laid
to rest in saint-petersburg like you
know as a czar would be so you know
they've kind of been given their
rightful place in history
despite the whole controversy about what
happened to them and whatnot so that's
how that went um I guess this probably
will wrap it up at this point cuz we've
probably got on long enough yeah and
you're probably like deep into the
Kukulcan it's I'm thinking about damn
the damn Russians you know I mean the
Russians were a good people they went
through a lot of [ __ ] hard [ __ ] and
you know I mean I'm hanging against them
I remember I remember everything we
dealt with their military after the
[ __ ] collapse the [ __ ] Soviet Union
my unit ended up had get
they're [ __ ] helicopters for testing
the long story don't worry about it
oh yeah oh I should say to canonizing
the Romanov family also the last house
where they were kept at patia house they
actually tore that down and they put a
church there all right so let's wrap up
this show about Rasputin and the
Romanovs hope you guys enjoyed episode
135 and remember if you like the show
please like share subscribe on all your
social media it really helps us out a
lot if you'd like to financially support
the show which would help us out anymore
haha you can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
in the side bar the side bar that says
PayPal like donate through PayPal so you
can push on that give a one-time
donation if you would like to do that
also remember check out our last movie
review which was the 1990 Joel
Schumacher flick Flatliners also check
out our Zazzle store which is zazzle.com
slash 13 o'clock which has a whole bunch
of t-shirts including the running with
kukulcan which took me a long time to
make but is up there now also I also
check out my board games and card games
at the game crafter calm and look for
giallo games I have three games up there
with expansion packs and stuff like that
all based around
Italian giallo movies like murder
mysteries and stuff like that so if your
do that kind of [ __ ] then check it out
and that will do it for episode 135 we
will see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]